il y à 40 ans le 29 mai 1982 la mort de
romy schneider elle avait pour elle le
talent la beauté et à 43 ans cette forme
de maturité alourdi par le malheur romy
schneider un mythe elle a tourné avec
les plus grands réalisateurs
je crois que c'est une forme de dison
disons le mot c'est une forme de génie
elle a une forme de génie c'est
quelqu'un de très généreux très
spontanée très absolue tenez luchino
visconti par exemple avant de faire
jouer romy schneider au cinéma le
metteur en scène italien lui donne sa
chance au théâtre dommage qu'elle soit
une [ __ ] oeuvre sulfureuse est la
première pièce de l'actrice tout ce que
je sais maintenant enfin pas tournée
tout ce que je sais faire
je peux faire maintenant c'est grâce à
vis compter ce qui m'a pris sur scène et
puis il était à 30 au collège le plus
difficile et plus dire mais notre les
meilleures écoles après luchino visconti
claude sautet son réalisateur fétiche
mais aussi son ami
au total ils tourneront cinq films
ensemble dont une histoire simple en
1978 vous avez donc tourné quatre films
avec rami est ce qu'elle vous étonne
encore
bonjour m dans ce film romy schneider y
joue le rôle d'une femme libre une
performance qui lui vaut le césar de la
meilleure actrice en 1979 la même année
elle tourne avec un autre réalisateur de
renom mais lui aussi exigeant costa
gavras pour le film clair de femme liste
des personnalités assez complexe
renfermé tout en étant très ouverte un
personnage très
très déchiré quelque part
autre réalisateur avec qui romy
schneider a tourné bertrand tavernier
c'était en 1980 avec le film
d'anticipation la mort en direct le
cinéaste n'hésitez pas à comparer
l'actrice un célèbre compositeur italien
je pense que c'est l'actrice la plus
émotionnelle que je connaisse la plus
vibrante et pour moi c'est ce qu'elle
fait c'est du cdu verdi dans le film
c'est beau selon les risques c'est le
grand lyrisme absolument et ce à une
actrice lyrique c'est assez rare elle
peut aller très très très très loin très
loin avec une générosité extraordinaire
deux ans plus tard en 1982 romy
schneider meurt à l'âge de 43 ans en
presque trente ans de carrière elle a
joué au total dans plus de 60 films
[Musique]